bon à tous merci de nous rejoindre en
direct sur france 3 normandie pour cette
fois analysé les résultats du second
tour de ces élections régionales qui a
vu hier soir très tardivement la
victoire d'hervé morin le candidat de
l'union de la droite et du centre qui a
remporté cette élection historique d'une
courte tête quelques 4700 52 voix juste
devant nicolas mayer rossignol président
socialiste de la région haute normandie
jusqu'à présent une victoire donc sur le
fil fêté à rouen hier soir dans son qg
est partout ailleurs dans ses
permanences normand bonjour franck
bonjour ml effectivement rarement une
soirée électorale n'aura connu appareils
suspense un pareil scénario
il a fallu compter chaque bulletin de
vote pour réussir à dégager le nom du
vainqueur
imaginez plutôt plus d'un million 400
mille personnes se sont rendues aux
urnes hier 4700 voix d'écart entre le
premier et le second un record de
participation également + 9 % par
rapport au premier tour 1 million 400
mille bulletins dépouillés et à
l'arrivée vers 21h45
et hier soir l'annoncé de la victoire
d'hervé morin le candidat de la droite
et du centre avec un score de 36,43 %
des voix 36,08 % pour son adversaire
nicolas mayer rossignol
nicolas bay pour le front national
obtient 27 50% des suffrages toute la
soirée on assister un chassé croisé au
fur et à mesure que les sondages
puis les résultats officiels tomber un
stress pour les candidats est une vraie
soir suspens pour les téléspectateurs
philippe goudé est bien sûr est avec
nous bonjour philippe on va revenir si
vous le voulez bien avec vous sur le
rapport de force forcément au sein de
l'hémicycle du conseil régional qui a
changé on n'est pas du tout sur le même
rapport de force qu'en 2010 notamment
par rapport au front national
absolument le front national a fait il a
connu une progression très importante
alors figurez-vous qu'en 90 vite le
front national avec 10 élus au sein du
conseil régional de haute-normandie
pardonnez moi je parle pas de la
basse-normandie parce qu'il n'y avait
pas d'élu à ce moment là et en
l'occurrence avec ses dix élus suite à
un scrutin à la proportionnelle
intégrale le front national a réussi à
bloquer l'institution ce qui a fait que
cette institution a été mise sous la
tutelle du préfet c'est là qu'on a
inventé le 49-3 régional et par la suite
il a été décidé justement d'introduire
une part de majorité au sein d'un
scrutin proportionnel ce qui fait que
cette année effectivement vous avez
raison il ya un écart très important au
niveau du nombre d'élus camembert alors
que vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure
avec 4700 voix sur plus d'un million et
demi de votants s'est très peu et bien
la droite se retrouve avec 54 élus
contre 27 pour le parti socialiste
essaie et ses collègues du parti
communiste et d'europe écologie les
verts
alors que le front national n'a que six
sièges de différence avec le parti
socialiste
donc c'est assez inédit quelque part ça
assure à la droite un fonctionnement
real parce que il ya une vraie majorité
non pour la suite il faut voir comment
ça va se passer au niveau des votes et
ça c'est une autre histoire
alors la tension est retombée depuis
l'annoncé officielle des résultats hier
soir quelle conséquence après cette
élection obtenu dans les arrêts de jeu
on pourrait dire on va en parler avec
nos invités dans un instant mais on
découvre ce dessin de chenu qui nous
accompagnent bon jour venu moi je en
france bonjour emilie à l'écouté il a
manqué quelques centimètres à au ponton
de nicolas mayer à signol pour pouvoir
accéder avait sur le drakkar de la
normandie c'est donc ni c'est donc hervé
morin qui lui filent aux traces drakkar
alors bon vent à lui jusqu'au bout du
bout de la nuit effectivement était 22
heures
presque cinquante minutes quand on a
appris le résultat officiel
du ministère de l'intérieur ça a été une
soirée chargée d'émotion pour hervé
morin et ses supporters une de nos
équipes les ont suivis jusqu'au
dénouement final c'est un reportage de
pierre marie peau et jean michel guillot
il avait au moins pris la précaution de
fêter la fin de campagne
après tout l'arithmétique n'étant pas
favorable à la droite
hervé morin ne se voyait pas forcément
gagnant alors un vote le maire
d'epaignes affiche même la décontraction
de la outsider au point qu'ils en
oublient de signer le registre
oubli réparé à 17h59 le dépouillement
achevée hervé morin chez moi je me
rasais ouailles et voila j'aimerais fils
et l'autre uniforme
il veut être en famille et quand
tomberont les résultats allaient tout à
l'heure
à rouen au siège des républicains
commence une longue attente crispante
une élection où tf1 donne des résultats
et france 2 le contraire l'estimation
d'ipsos donne bien une avance à la
gauche mais la rumeur laisse présager
une toute autre issue le dernier à la
fédé ps qui m'a dit on a perdu nos fils
ils m'ont volé car c'est pourtant à
écouter on peut pas dire que ce soit une
élection c'est la première fois de ma
vie que je vis un tel suspense je veux
dire que je suis parti de la maison en
ayant perdu j'ai fait la route on
découvre les résultats au fur et à
mesure et voilà donc bon ça a été un
moment c'est ça soit bull c'est vous
pouvez le dire comme ça devant les
micros et les caméras
hervé morin essaye de trouver les mots
de circonstance pour dire qu'il va très
vite se mettre au travail
mais dans l'immédiat il a surtout envie
d'une petite sphère où il s'en va la
faire tout à l'heure
voilà beaucoup d'émotion donc hier soir
auprès des militants on l'a vu on va
revenir avec vous invité en plateau sur
cette grande soirée si vous le voulez
bien je m'adresser à vous peut-être bien
de gens de là bâti puisque vous êtes
proche d'hervé morin cette élection
véritablement c'est un peu un
aboutissement pour lui lui qui prônait
la réunification depuis presque 20 ans
aujourd'hui
alors c'est le fruit d'un très long
travail d'un très longue attachement à
la normandie puisque comme vous le savez
n'est ses racines familiales en
normandie est depuis toujours nous
sommes au sein d'une association qui
milite pour le regroupement des deux
normandies donc c'est l'aboutissement
effectivement d'un long travail d'une
longue quête pour la réunification de la
normandie et aussi d'un long travail de
conviction près tous nos concitoyens
le résultat de cette élection là en fait
traduit le fait on était énormément sur
le terrain pour expliquer tous les
avantages qu'ils auraient à une bonne
vitesse lui même avait du mal à y croire
hier d'air on savait depuis le départ
que ce serait très serré si vous
regardez les sondages dont tout début de
campagne on savait que ça se jouerait à
très peu nous avons des adversaires qui
connaissent également la politique et
qui font de bonnes campagnes et donc il
fallait faire valoir nos arguments ce
que nous avons fait et enfants bien
évidemment en plus nous avons réalisé
l'union dès le premier tour ce qui nous
a permis d'avoir une clarté totale dans
nos discours alors que guy lefrand vous
êtes maire d'evreux vous connaissez bien
hervé morin qui va devenir le 4 janvier
prochain le nouveau le premier président
même de la grande normandie
quelles sont ses qualités quels sont ses
défauts je crois que sa principale
qualité ça a été dit par hubert c'est
aujourd'hui la proximité la connaissance
du territoire la connaissance de la
normandie et surtout des normands et ça
pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'important sa deuxième qualité c'est de
savoir faire travailler les gens en
équipe et aujourd'hui nous savons déjà
comment nous allons travailler nous
savons déjà quelles vont être les
premiers projets moi aujourd'hui en tant
que maire d'evreux président de
l'agglomération d'evreux mais je sais
déjà que nous allons travailler avec lui
sur la vidéoprotection sur quelques
projets économiques que nous avons
à mettre en oeuvre sur du travail sur
l'aménagement du territoire avec les
routes avec le train étaient des faux on
parlait est-ce qu'il en a missionné je
n'ai pas encore trouvé
mais je ne désespère pas non voilà vous
parlez comme un politique
non je je je je crois à travers vous
aider oui je je je ne doute pas que les
uns et les autres pourront lui et lui
trouver des défauts
moi ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
que le nouveau président de la région
normandie et les qualités pour pouvoir
présider cette région c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui est important et
qu'attendent les électeurs qui lui ont
fait confiance
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence dans
cet entre-deux tours parce que tous les
candidats ont mobilisé à gauche et une
union voilà on a vu qu effectivement la
participation avait été beaucoup plus
importante mais on a le sentiment qu'il
ya eu un vrai travail de labour entre
guillemets du terrain dans les campagnes
de votre part dans les campagnes et dans
les villes puisque nous l'avons vu nous
progressons au nombre de voix par
rapport au premier tour
je pense qu'il ya eu un vrai sursaut
républicain le front national a fait
peur certains se sont dit oui il ya un
risque effectivement que front national
puisse gagner la région puisqu'il était
deuxième est très peu au premier tour
donc il ya eu un vrai sursaut de la part
de la gauche comme de la part de la
droite
je crois que nous avons eu nous une
mobilisation exceptionnelle les reports
de voix de la gauche n'ont pas été
complet on l'a bien vu cette liste un
peu vert rouge rose n'a pas fait
l'unanimité partout
je crois que c'est ce qui nous a permis
justement en dernier ressort de gagner
cette élection
la normandie on retiendra aussi
permettez moi on a recentré les enjeux
sur la région auprès de plus aux
habitants en mettant en valeur les
candidats sur les listes pour valoriser
le travail d'une équipe et non pas
seulement d'un homme qui conduit la
liste mais de toute l'équipe parce que
nous avions des équipes de grande
qualité
donc la normandie je le disais à son
président il officiera à partir du mois
de janvier
stéphane travert il ya eu cette union de
la gauche effectivement entre les
écologistes parti socialiste le front de
gauche sébastien jumel est à côté de
vous justement
mais comment expliquer que vous ayez eu
tant de faveur temps de voir promise
pour ce second tour avec un rapport de
force qui vous étaient favorables que
finalement vous ayez perdu cette
élection
a été perdu 2 peut vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé et joua en même temps ça
s'est joué à rien 0 3% c'est peanuts
dans une dans une élection comme comme
celle là nous avions effectivement fait
le rassemblement pour le deuxième tour
avec les forces écologistes et le parti
communiste et le front de gauche est une
fierté pour nous pour de l'avoir de
l'avoir fait les repas de pouvoir de vos
résultats plutôt bons sur un certain
nombre de départements jeu ce que j'ai
pu constater c'était le cas dans le dans
le département de la manche un peu moins
bon par ailleurs et la mobilisation qui
est arrivé moi je crois que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut souligner le
fait que les électrices et les électeurs
aient décidé de retourner aux urnes
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
vème république de voir cette
progression en nombre de participations
et je crois que c'est ces électeurs se
sont plus mobilisés en faveur de en
faveur de la droite républicaine des
gens qui n'étaient pas allés voter au
premier tour et on aboutit à ce résultat
aujourd'hui qui est décevant bien
évidemment mais c'est toujours décevant
lorsque l'on échoue à si peu aussi près
du but mais c'est le jeu il faut en
accepter l'auguré
sébastien jumel justement est ce que
l'union de la gauche ne vous a pas fait
prendre trop confiance par rapport à la
droite on entendait tout à l'heure qui
est allé chercher les abstentionnistes
on a même entendu que il y avait eu des
coups de fil personnel d'hervé morin aux
maires des petites communes pour aller
chercher chaque voix c'est 4500 voix qui
font la différence au second tour mais
écoutez le renard de stratégie lors de
votre côté le résultat ne permet à
personne de fanfaronner la france va mal
la france est éclatée et déchiré et le
peuple et en désespérance et donc moi ma
préoccupation de conseiller régional qui
désormais va prendre
le chemin de l' opposition combative
c'est de répondre aux problèmes porté
par les gens c'est de porter la colère
et la désespérance essaie d'y répondre
très concrètement de quoi mathon parlé
ce matin sur le chemin de l'école
lorsque j'ai amené ma fille à l'école du
chômage de la nécessité de trouver des
solutions de formation pour les jeunes
de quoi j'ai envie de parler moi dès le
4 janvier du désenclavement ferroviaire
promis du bouclage du plan de
financement du transmanche annoncée de
la nécessité de n'oublier aucun
territoire dans la construction de cette
nouvelle normandie
j'ai envie qu'on parle de l'avenir de
l'hôpital de gisors de vernon de tréport
j'ai envie qu'on me dise comment on va
porter la parole des pêcheurs dans
l'hémicycle régional j'ai envie qu'on
n'apporte des solutions aux salariés de
sidel du blast savait simplement comment
vous expliquez votre défaite pour être
clair j'explique le fait que le
gouvernement lorsqu'il mène une
politique de droite sert la droite alors
que le peuple de gauche aspire à
retrouver de l'espérance à gauche et moi
je souhaite réveiller la gauche et
redonner du souffle à la gauche c'est
l'énergie que je vais déployer dans
l'hémicycle régional est ce que du coup
l'union de la gauche la stratégie de
s'unir entre les deux tours fonctionne
encore mais le le le boulot dans le
rassemblement a été fait mais vous avez
vu comme moi que les abstentionnistes du
premier tour qui se sont déplacés au
second était plus à droite et au fn que
à gauche
il convient donc de s'interroger
pourquoi le peuple de gauche est resté
chez lui et moi j'ai une réponse à cela
le peuple de gauche il attend des
réponses sur le renouveau industriel sur
la protection sociale à la française sur
l'avenir des services publics cambadélis
lui même dit au gouvernement il faut
changer le matrix vous imaginez ce que
sébastien jumel peut dire au
gouvernement
il faut abandonner la dérive libérale et
l'austérité et mettre en oeuvre une
politique véritablement de gauche
si nous faisons si nous le faisons nous
redonnerons de l'espoir et la
perspective à gauche thimothée au sein
pour le front national
eh bien nous
constatons que les communistes critique
toujours ce que font les socialistes
mais qu'il s'allie à eux à chaque fois
qu'il s'agit de sauver leur siège
vous servez la droite à chaque fois que
vos intérêts perso lui ment pas monsieur
nous on se maintient partout où nous
sommes présents aux examens
voir il a pu observer hier nous avons
réalisé un résultat tout à fait
favorable auparavant nous représentions
à peu près 10% des voix cela normandie
hier nous avons réalisé 28% des
suffrages qui est la plus forte
progression des différents partis dans
la région cela va nous permettre de
faire entrer à 21 conseillers régionaux
au conseil régional et d'y mener une
politique politiques d'opposition
constructive c'est à dire que nous
verrons si les différents projets qui
sont proposés par la majorité vont dans
le sens de l'intérêt général dans ce cas
là nous les voteront
et puis quand nous verrons des projets
qui semblent aller al'inverse de
l'intérêt général nous ne la nous nous y
opposerons formellement et puis nous
pourrons communiquer auprès des normands
1 sur ce que nous pensons de la
politique menée par la majorité le clan
le pen a pris une déculottée d'ailleurs
sous les 7%
on a ressorti le père le pen qui donnait
des leçons de doctrine à sa fille on
voit bien que le front national est
d'ailleurs bien à droite de cette de ce
plateau
il est positionné clairement à droite et
il n'a pas vocation à apporter de
solution c'est pour ça monsieur jumelles
que chaque fois qu'on va sur le terrain
on rencontre des anciens électeurs
socialistes des anciens électeurs
communistes qui petit à petit viennent
chez nous parce qu'il considère que nous
nous défendons encore nous aident les
candidats de naisey les granges dont
encore vous êtes les grilles des
réalisations que nous nous aident des
candidats politiques vis-à-vis de la
sécurité par exemple qu'ils attendent et
que vous ne fournissez pas d'ailleurs
elle ne vous considère pas comme une
alternative au ps puisque la vague rue
est critiquée à jamais la télé mais vous
êtes allés avec eux dès qu'ils seraient
vos mandats on va revenir à la soirée si
vous le voulez bien qui restera gravé
aussi dans l'esprit de nicolas mayer
rossignol l'ex président de la région
haute normandie a connu tous les états
hier soir donne ex-aequo puis vainqueur
il a ensuite cédé sa place à hervé morin
en milieu de soirée l'ancien président
de la région haute-normandie soutenu par
laurent bouvet celui de la basse
normandie qui était à ses côtés sur
notre plateau
hier soir on les écoute assumer leur
défaite on ne peut pas faire l'autruche
il faut renouveler notre façon de faire
la politique il faut du renouveau
politique pas profondément qu'on soit à
droite ou à gauche qu'on a besoin de
changer la façon de faire parce que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne croit
plus ne croient plus en action publique
ce qu'on voit c'est que nous avons fait
un score qui est élevée nous échoue je
rappelle quand même qu'on était donné
perdant depuis le début donc on peut
être déçu et on est évidemment déçu de
perdre mais au final on peut se dire
aussi qu'on a failli gagner alors quand
on nous donnait perdant et ce score il
nous oblige mais j'avais dire il oblige
aussi le vainqueur j'ai plutôt sentiment
que pour ce qui concerne l'action que
j'ai conduite en basse normandie
nous avons fait des choses très positif
pour ce territoire ou portions
d'ailleurs ces choses positives à côté
de la haute normandie pour demain voilà
je reste beaucoup de remerciements à
tous ceux qui nous ont soutenus après
l'analyse plus précise du scrutin
méritera de passer un petit peu de temps
les villes les campagnes
évidemment je crois que ça saute aux
yeux voilà pour ce alors nicolas mayer
rossignol a donc dû s'adapter hier soir
mais cette très courte défaite c'est
évidemment pour lui une grosse déception
pour celui qui avait hérité de la région
après alain le vern pour celui qui se
confrontaient aussi pour la toute
première fois au choix des électeurs
virginie du croquet et didier meunier
l'ont suivi durant cette soirée regarder
cette écharpe rouge autour du cou elle
ne vous a pas quittés de la campagne
c'est un grigri c'est un hasard c'est un
symbole non pas du tout c'est les
charges que j'ai depuis des années et
des années pour tout vous dire je ne
donnerait pas le détail mais c'est une
vieille échappe c'est tout après
quelques mois de campagne nicolas mayer
rossignol s'est accommodé de la présence
des médias
il attend que chacun fasse son image
puis il dépose son bulletin
et c'est parti pour la tournée des
bureaux de vote
en compagnie de valérie fourneyron et de
kader chick et manille allez bonne
journée aller
le trio suscite la bienveillance ah oui
oui il ya plus de monde dans les bureaux
que l'on connaît il ya plus de monde
beaucoup plus la participation est en
hausse assez peut-être bon signe
toujours mieux que les gens votent
après comment les gens votent pas
poutine
l'élection sera très serré un
journaliste du monde alors s'il est dans
le monde nicolas mayer rossignol le sait
mais il se plaît à arborer une bonne
humeur qui n'est pas feinte à la
fédération départementale du ps
en fin d'après-midi le candidat
chantonne mais son regard est grave il
s'amuse un instant à nous faire un quiz
musical du chanteur
mais c'est pas possible david lee roth
oui mais retient paul guitariste il s'y
connaît
et puis nous sommes priés de sortir la
porte se ferme et les visages aussi
alain le vern
laurent beauvais sont arrivés à 21h
c'est très tendu nicolas mayer rossignol
restent enfermés jusqu'à 22 heures
il a perdu moins de 5000 voix d'écart
le s'ouvrir et énigmatique comme il sait
si bien le faire la voix blanche
merci merci en fin de soirée l'émission
télé est un passage obligé les déçus
quand on perd voilà après c'est pas la
fin du monde non plus faut pas exagérer
on est déçu
le cerveau est désormais dans
l'opposition à la le cerveau est
désormais dans l'opposition et chenu qui
dessine
heureusement j'ai mon doudou bien style
moderne nicolas mayer rossignol stéphane
travert mais bien sûr c'était une
élection régionale
ces bons candidats des périodiques comme
ça et j'aime la porte quand il veut plus
voir les journalistes
c'est une manière de faire et je crois
que il a insufflé une dynamique durant
cette campagne
un autre style une autre manière de
faire de la politique et c'est ce dont
nous avons aujourd'hui besoin et nous
nous sommes un certain nombre à nous
reconnaître aussi dans ceux dans ce dans
ce style et c'était important de pouvoir
afficher aussi un renouvellement et
aujourd'hui c'est un conseil régional
profondément renouvelée qui va diriger
présider aux destinées de la de la
normandie et je crois que c'est bien à
un moment nous aurions sans doute
préféré que notre nous le renouvellement
soit plus de notre côté mais il n'en a
pas été ainsi mais je crois que avec
nicolas mayer rossignol nous avons
pendant cette campagne crée des ponts
entre la haute et la basse normandie et
je crois que c'était important et
il l'a fait de la plus belle des
manières le style la bannière de
président et vous connaissez bien hervé
morin tous les deux et c'est à guy
lefrand et hubert dejean de la bâtie de
président sera-t-il ou souhaitez vous
qu'il soit alors déjà elle vous
connaissez la personnalité des remémora
vous l'avez évoqué vous savez que c'est
quelqu'un qui est direct qui est très
déterminé et qui ne lâche jamais c'est
la raison d'ailleurs du fait qu'il a
insufflé aux équipes autour de lui la
volonté d'aller sur le terrain de
défendre nos idées et finalement de
gagner je vous rappelle que on parlait
de renouvellement il y à une alternance
après 17 années de pouvoir socialiste à
la région haute normandie nous avons une
alternance nous le souhaitions ne
l'avons obtenue sans thil sera bel et
bien en direct et je reviens sur la
détermination nous sommes décidés à nous
battre pour obtenir un certain nombre de
choses à commencer dans le domaine des
trains avec guînes travaillons sur la
question et ça va être un très gros
sujet moi j'ai une question pour
stéphane travert à votre avis que fera
nicolas mayer rossignol maintenant je
vous pose cette question parce que il
n'est pas vraiment du sérail politique
entre guillemets il s'est dit très libre
il était très très déçu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va continuer la politique
bien sûr enfin c'est c'est à lui de
répondre à cette question quels seront
ses choix mais votre personnage
mon sentiment c'est que il a incarné un
espoir il ya des gens qui lui font
confiance
aujourd'hui et des gens de tout le
territoire et que cette confiance c'est
bien on doit l'honorer en siégeant bien
évidemment et en travaillant dans
l'opposition en étant constructif certes
mais en étant aussi vigilant parce que
beaucoup d'annonce beaucoup de promesses
ont été faites un train toutes les 40
minutes entre caen et rend une quatre
voies entre avranches et granville à un
route nationale 12 quasiment couverte et
en quatre voies partout le 100 millions
d'euros d'investissements gb retenu le
programme pour les entreprises
célia je demande je demande à voir et
nous et nous jugerons sur les actes nous
jugerons sur les faits encore faut-il
que l'ensemble de cette majorité vienne
vienne siéger et nous verrons comment
les choses se passeront en tous les cas
l'opposition que nous
carnon désormais elle sera au service
des normands elle sera présente sur
l'ensemble du territoire et nous serons
vigilants bien évidemment canto au
promes qui ont été faites aux normands
pendant cette campagne et nous serons
déterminés offensif mais aussi
constructif parce que quand les choses
iront dans le bon sens parce que nous
avons commencé à travailler
nous avons semé un certain nombre de
choses durant ces dernières ces
dernières années notamment sur les
politiques maritimes sur les politiques
en charge des délices et sur le
transport nous avons le mont saint
michel
nous avons un certain nombre de pépites
dans cette dans cette région qui font de
cette région un talisman connu dans le
monde entier
je crois que à partir de là il faudra
doser
chacun saura ce qu'il a fermé mais j'y
reviens quand même stéphane travert et
sébastien jumel qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné quand je pense par exemple au
succès de monsieur le drian bretagne est
ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu s' s'allier
s'unir des premiers tubes prête dès le
premier tour pardon c'était pas c'était
pas envisageable moi je je je pense
vraiment que parce que monsieur le drian
il avait des communistes ils avaient des
verts aussi sur sa liste mais un très
mauvais candidat en face ici il n'ya pas
d'union mais il avait quelques verres il
y avait un qui provenaient des berges il
y là il a bénéficié de l'aura du
ministre et ça compte dans la période
particulière
qui était sale de la france ceci étant
dit moi je pense vraiment que ce qui a
fait mal c'est la réforme des collages
où les enseignants qui sont plutôt un
électorat de gauche sont restées très
perplexe sur les coups portés à l'égard
du service public de l'éducation
ce qui a fait mal c'est l'avenir du
système de santé publique vous vous
souvenez de cette carte du journal le
monde qui juxtapose la désertification
médicale avec l'augmentation du repli
sur soi et de l'obscurantisme ainsi que
les électeurs normand et oui bien sûr
parce que vous avez vu que cet objet
j'ai parlé j'ai parlé de france éclaté
on voit bien à quel point pour reprendre
mickey 3d ce chanteur actuelle il dit la
france a peur tous les tous les soirs au
20 heures la france a peur et la france
est éclatée il convient de répondre à
ses préoccupations à ses aspirations à
ces peurs mais d'y répondre concrètement
pas pour les alimenter pas pour souffler
dessus mais pour répondre à la question
clé vous savez trois priorités pour les
gens l'emploi l'éducation et la
formation
et puis la santé si on répond
correctement à ces trois préoccupations
à l'échelle nationale alors je vous
assure que le peuple va retrouver le
chemin de la combativité d'espérance
c'est cela que nous allons porter dans
l'hémicycle régional et être
effectivement attentif aux promesses
mois lundi enfin entre les deux tours
pascal martin dit hervé morin dès lundi
annoncera ont une course départementale
de cette marque annoncera dès lundi une
contribution financière au lien
transmanche
de combien et l es ce que vous avez
envisagé de combien quand ya pas de
réponse je voyais bien que on a là
affaire à des promesses de gascon le le
le morin est à l'étude
morin est allé rencontrer les pêcheurs
du tréport en disant vous verrez ce que
vous allez voir et bien puisque vous
êtes le maire devient le nord du
département est le 37 fois que nous y
avons fait le compte
elles seront portées dans l'hémicycle
régional en disant aux pêcheurs vous
pouvez compter sur moi on s'opposera au
parc éolien offshore chiche
moi je suis pour une relocalisation du
parc éolien offshore qui ne percute pas
le monde de la pêche
mais là encore bien j'attends chez moi
c'est bien mais pas en zone de
reproduction de bages
de la même manière moi j'entends je
laissais oblige entrant j'entends sur
les trains ou les met sur les pas de
trêve les pêcheurs ont proposé dans le
cadre du débat public
des propositions très précises de
relocalisation validé par l'ifremer est
validée par les scientifiques qui ne
percute pas dans le monde de la page
aurait clair à quelques miles de
différence au large des côtes aux a fait
quand les pêcheurs étaient pour et nous
étions pour au tréport les pêcheurs sont
contre et nous sommes contre les trains
enfin moi je suis préparé des trains les
trains intercity soir entre la vie dans
toute la région normande bien une chose
que vous disiez est ce que la france a
peur justement c'est une question est ce
que ça peut expliquer la progression du
front national
l'évoqué dans un instant le front
national qui a triplé son score comparé
aux dernières élections régionales de
2010 en haute et basse normandie
il avait fait 13 % notamment 10 8% en
basse normandie
le fn qui n'a pas profité d'un bon
report de voix
il se heurter à ce fameux plafond de
verre qui l'empêchent toujours de
remporter ce type d'élection n'êtes pas
d'accord
timothée août saint auvent parler dans
un instant le fn qui dans certains cas a
même reculé de la première à la
troisième place d'un tour à l'autre
exemple dans l'orne avec ce sujet de
damien mignot et carole lefrançois
loool à l'annoncé des résultats les
visages sont graves
la vague bleue marine s'est retirée du
territoire la mobilisation dont les
bureaux de vote leur a été fatal on est
impressionné c'est normal mais on n'est
pas non plus dès ce on est déçu
finalement aussi un petit peu mais je
veux dire nous on a au moins l'honnêteté
de cette présenter tout seul de ne pas
faire d'alliance avec personne ce qui
est pas le contraire c'est que ce n'est
pas le pas des autres partis qui ont
fait alliance socialiste avec la droite
on n'a jamais vu ça en tête au premier
tour dans l'orne le front national
marque également le pas dans ce
département
alors comment garder la face un soir de
défaite petite leçon de rhétorique la
première qualité c'est d'être
rassembleur on a rassemblé tout le monde
les grands médias v républicains lui dit
le modem le parti socialiste les
écologistes le front de gauche
communistes on a rassemblé contre vous
voilà on les à rassembler quand même un
rassemblement républicain qui selon les
chiffres c'est avant tout opéré dans les
villes dans les campagnes le fn réalise
encore de très bons scores
moi j'habite à la campagne ça se voit
les gens osent dire qu'ils votent fn qui
veut depuis longtemps fn est bien à des
nouveaux n'ont jamais voté
qui ose le dire une soirée donc en demi
teinte pour le front national où ses
militants ont déjà le regard tourné vers
d'autres élections
voilà le front national qui a donc
réalisé un score par l'intermédiaire de
nicolas bay de 27,40 9% des suffrages
philippe le fn a progressé dans notre
région et en particulier on l'a vu dans
ce reportage dans les zones rurales
j'ai peur de casser l'ambiance je veux
dire pourquoi parce que c'est un
discours qu'on entend souvent à gauche
et à droite le front national a certes
finalement est un parti de premier tour
et au deuxième tour finalement on tourne
la page et on passe à autre chose
il va bien falloir un jour que
l'intelligentsia politiques s'opposent
véritablement les questions entendu hier
l'avait dit l'avion de ce travers vous
l'avez dit également monsieur lefranc
hier soir on a bien entendu m
absolument il va bien falloir pour
devrait s'intéresser aux gens qui
souffrent et qui ont l'occasion de
s'exprimer en votant pour le front
national
alors d'une certaine façon la démocratie
fonctionne parce que peut-être que ces
personnes dans certains endroits je
pense pas particulièrement à la
normandie mais dans l'outrance endroits
notamment dans le nord pas de calais
pourrait se retrouver dans les rues en
dix ans après tout on ne nous entend pas
et c est le meilleur exemple si que je
pourrais donner c'est celui 2005 au
moment du vote sur la réforme
constitutionnelle du parlement européen
et je me souviens qu'à l'époque et je
crois d'ailleurs que monsieur houssin
est rentré au front national dans sa
famille plus ou moins dans cette période
là et c'est probablement pas le seul
on a demandé au peuple de s'exprimer le
peuple a dit non
et finalement c'est le parlement qui a
eu le dernier mot
et ça c'est vrai que c'est quelque part
un problème et il va falloir à un moment
ou à un autre
qu'on arrête de stigmatiser des gens qui
votent pour le front national
stigmatiser le front national ça fait
partie du débat démocratique c'est tout
à fait normal et peut-être arriver à
discuter avec des gens qu'on rencontre
tous les jours qui font partie de nos
entreprises dans nos familles etc et qui
pose comme disait monsieur raymond barre
une certaine époque peut-être quelques
vraies questions sont à porter
obligatoirement les vraies réponses mais
ça ça va partie du départ dont 375 mille
personnes ont voté front national
hier lors de ce second tour en normandie
jouer sa parole promis timothée houssin
dans un instant on va écouter celui qui
menait la liste fn pour toute la
normandie à savoir nicolas bay on n'a
pas encore atteint tout à fait le niveau
critique pour gagner mais je remarque
quand même que ce soir nous avons la
coalition de différents partis de gauche
qui obtient 36% des voix la coalition de
plusieurs partis de droite qui obtient
36% des voix et le front national seul
qu'un obtient quand même près de
vingt-huit donc c'est évidemment très
encourageants on a un tripartisme qui
s'installe dans la vie politique
normande et moi mon objectif c'est que
dans ce trip artistes ne vient
progressivement dans les mois dans les
années qui viennent le front national de
vienne la force la plus importante on
voit bien que ça se joue à pas grand
chose se joue à pas grand chose mais ça
se joue sur une élection également
puisque on a parlé de ça vous fait pas
plaisir je le sais qu'ils votaient au
sein de ce fameux plafond de verre que
vous n'arrivez pas à franchir qui vous
bloque parce que notamment vous n'avez
pas d'alliés non il n'y a pas eu l'hiver
pour moi il ya un an 19 m départ du
manager international de 2010 et celle
de 2015
on a triplé notre nombre de voix je
pense que personne d'autre en france
aucun autre parti ne peut en dire autant
par ailleurs ce qui est aussi à noter
c'est qu'on avale un véritable vote
d'adhésion
auparavant dans les cas de triangulaire
on perdait des voix or on voit dans les
résultats d'hier que malgré le sondage
qui est sorti en fin de semaine dernière
qui donnait vraiment un coude à coude
interv et morin et nicolas mayer
rossignol
malgré les médias les différents partis
politiques qui ont fait une campagne
très forte contre le front national
pendant toute la semaine nous avons
maintenu notre score en pourcentage donc
nous avons gardé nos électeurs du
premier tour mais nous avons aussi gagné
55 mille voix entre les deux tours ce
qui est quand même pas négligeable
et puis ça nous permet aujourd'hui
d'être au sein du conseil régional la
première force d'opposition puisque nous
nous avons 21 élus mais il faut bien
rappeler que le parti socialiste qui est
la deuxième force d'opposition d'un acte
18 adrian encore quelques années le
parti socialiste c'était 60 % des voix
en normandie
et aujourd'hui ils n'ont pu que 18
représentants dans l'assemblée et leurs
alliés à leur permettre d'en avoir 27 et
pas de région à la fin c'était grain
région à la fin mais au niveau au niveau
des régions c'est la même chose on
constate une excellente dynamique
ils se sont tous alliés contre nous du
parti communiste juste
à l'ump ils se sont désistés les
socialistes ont même choisi de ne plus
avoir du tout d'élus en or et en paca
pour pouvoir faire cette alliance contre
nous et en faisant cet immense alliance
ils nous battent de quelques points
auparavant par exemple en 2002 lorsqu'il
s'alliait tous contre nous il faisait 80
2 on faisait 18 maintenant il se dit
tous contre nous ils font 55 ont fait 45
c'est quand même une très forte
progression et qui progresse d'élection
en élection avec un soft qui se
construit et des gens qui nous viennent
des différents partis qui commencent à
voter pour nous et qui d'élection en
élection reste chez nous et qui on voit
arriver de nouveaux électeurs d'horizons
très divers
guy lefrand le front national grignotent
aussi dans les campagnes
bien souvent placé à droite la plupart
du temps oui enfin parce que ce que je
vous ai expliqué le département
largement salle d'abord aujourd'hui
c'est que hervé morin son équipe ont la
victoire humble je pense que en face
certains devraient peut-être aussi avoir
la défaite modeste parce que finalement
il ya ceux qui ont gagné il ya ceux qui
ont perdu même un peu de vous après et
ça c'est la démocratie qui a parlé donc
je pense qu'il faut que les uns et les
yeux nous sachions rester modeste parce
que il y a une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui et il ne suffit plus de dire
que je vous ai entendus pour que ça
fonctionne maintenant il faut comprendre
pourquoi les électeurs sont inquiet de
ce qu'ils ressentent comme une
acculturation
pourquoi nos électeurs sont inquiets
parce qu'ils ressentent un abandon
notamment dans les zones rurales où ils
se sont totalement et moi d'écouter mes
ça fait j'ai l'impression des années
pour le dit mais justement maintenant il
est maintenant excusez moi monsieur je
vous ai laissé parler il ya la politesse
de me laisser parler je crois que
aujourd'hui il est temps justement d'en
prendre conscience et d'assurer leur
nouveau bruno le maire l'a très bien dit
hier soit maintenant il faut changer
d'époque il faut changer de comportement
et avec hervé morin nous allons nous
mettre au travail dès le 4 janvier dès
lors qu'il sera officiellement président
de région de manière à pouvoir
travailler dès les premières semaines
sur la sécurité puisqu'il a assuré qu'il
allait accompagner les collectivités qui
le souhaitent pour développer la
vidéoprotection c'est une demande
importante de nos concitoyens il nous
allons travailler sur l'économie très
rapidement parce qu'aujourd'hui là c'est
ce qu'il nous reste
les électeurs du front national
justement c'est une question qui était
posée qu'il est d'ailleurs proposée par
nicolas sarkozy qui se votent front
national il faut l'entendre il faut
respecter les gens qui se sont tournés
vers le front national
mais je crois que chaque électeur est un
spectacle tout chaque voix chaque voix
est totalement respectée il ne s'agit
pas de thé nous sommes dans la politique
justement vous mènerez à la région est
ce que il faut prendre en compte
certaines propositions du front national
il faut être particulièrement claire sûr
mais c'est très simple il faut que notre
programme soient appliquées nous avons
gagné ces élections certains ont un peu
tendance à l'oublier nous avons gagné
hier soir ces élections sur un programme
sur une équipe nous allons mettre en
oeuvre ce programme qui donne une
priorité à l'économie et à l'emploi
ensuite à la sécurité ensuite à la
réduction des dépenses publiques ne
oublions pas aujourd'hui certains
prônent l'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires à la région nous nous
avons choisi et nous avons été élus pour
ça pour réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires
c'est là dessus que nous devons nous
battre ce n'est pas sur le programme des
autres nous devons travailler c'est sur
notre programme c'est là dessus que nous
avons gagné
alors regardez juan démentira pas bleu
rouge regardons justement si vous le
voulez bien
cette fameuse répartition on va on va la
retrouver pour qu'on puisse bien se
rendre compte de la répartition des
sièges au sein du conseil régional s'il
vous plaît messieurs alors si on regarde
bien est ce qu'on peut leur avoir cette
planète c'est possible ok donc voilà la
droite qui se positionne avec quand que
tu exactement la gauche francs 27 sièges
et le fn alors ce qui fait que la
normandie aujourd'hui se retrouvent en
bleu et avec sa région et avec ces
départements on a parlé d' un g6 où en
serions nous de cette question messieurs
est ce que c'est concret alors j'ai si
souvent expliquer simplement unissent et
les cinq départs i5 et i3 et la région
qui est détenu par la droite mais je
crois que c'est c'est on ne peut plus
concret est on ne peut plus urgent au
jeu nous avions président de région
haute normandie qui a tout mis sur la
région rouennaise et a complètement
délaissé le reste de notre région et
c'est aussi une des raisons du vote très
important du front national dans leur
notamment qui s'est sentie complètement
délaissé complètement abandonnée quand
on donnait 1 millions d'euros pour le
festival rock de roi et 80000 euros pour
le festival rock d'evreux évidemment on
crée une différence entre les
territoires
c'est justement cette équité entre les
territoires que nous devons rétablir
aujourd'hui et le g6 doit y participer
en étant tous autour de la table et en
travaillant sérieusement et non pas en
faisant des clientes et avec au même
moment
si je peux continuer un festival qui se
déroulait à hérouville saint clair le
festival regards il faisait comme tu
reviens je marche très bien qui
accueille des dizaines de milliers de
personnes et qui était en pleine
concurrence justement avec les concerts
gratuits de rouen est en passe de ce
réseau dont à trouver un accord en deux
volets de région mais comment justement
faire s'entendre c'est deux anciennes
régions faire qu'il y ait une grande
normandie je vais m'adresser à claude
taleb pour écologie les verts simplement
vont répartir le temps politique
il n'a pas parlé encore que le talent
est juste un mot sur la défaite de la
gauche d'abord et de votre candidat
nicolas mayer rossignol
bon évidemment évidemment déçu et
évidemment envie de faire un examen de
conscience je pense qu on est au
lendemain d'élections n'est plus en
campagne électorale je le ferai donc je
pense qu'il faut regarder ce qu'il n'y a
pas fonctionné et très clairement échoué
donc les raisons de l'échec elles sont
sans doute multiples on est aujourd'hui
au lendemain de la coupe 21 ils vous
appellent chapelet que le sujet du
réchauffement climatique des mesures
qu'on pouvait prendre pour faire la
rénovation thermique la transition
énergétique mais pas du tout été ou très
peu à l'ordre du jour du débat des
régionales donc on a échoué à mettre ces
questions au coeur du débat des
régionales on a échoué à convaincre nos
concitoyens que l'élection régionale ça
servait pas d'abord ou à sanctionner
françois hollande ou à refaire ou à
préparer d'autres matches à venir mais
ça devait servir à regarder ce qu'ils
allaient pouvoir devenir la normandie et
encore on allait pouvoir être utile pour
repos construire cette normandie donc
moi je prends ma part très volontiers on
n'a pas réussi
on parlait tout à l'heure de respecter
les électeurs je veux quand même
rappeler que 70 me normand voter pour la
liste de yannick soubien au premier tour
donc ce sont aussi des électeurs se sont
exprimés
on est il y en avait un peu plus de cent
mille en 2010 on a perdu mais on a perdu
plus de 30% des voix et ne reste pas
moins que je savais que c'était facile à
léa démocratique ou moi j'accepte tout à
fait le résultat mais je crois qu on est
dans un état ya donc il ya des moments
bas il ya des moments de hautes vosges
je pense que 70 mille électeurs ça
doivent néanmoins ça doit quand même
être entendu un le le moi je regrette
beaucoup quand même que cette campagne
on ait parlé de sécurité ou de des biens
des personnes alors qu'on sait
parfaitement vous savez pertinemment que
ça n'est pas une compétence des régions
1 plutôt que se demander quelle
industrie d'avenir on pouvait développer
en s'engageant résolument dans la
transition énergétique c'est un regret
pour nous mais je pense que c'est une
demande de serre qui n'avons pas su sans
doute mettre ça au coeur du débat des
régionales donc
dans les priorités quand on interroge
les gens dans la rue quand on fait ces
sondages on s'aperçoit qu'il y a emploi
sécurité qui font partie justement des
thèmes qu'ils veulent voir mais op oui
bien sûr ce sont les thèmes que quand on
pose la question aux gens ils ont envie
effectivement devoir développer c'est
normal parce qu'ils subissent une
semaine situation on a connu des
événements gravissimes évidemment il ya
un mois qui vont conditionner les
esprits au dessin des autres mais
l'honnêteté nous commande de dire que le
pouvoir d'action la matière est
quasiment égal à néant il ya quasiment
égal à 0 1 c'est pas je pense pas que
les normands attend d'eux de la future
région de monsieur mourra comme action
principale la vidéosurveillance dans les
lycées peut-être à la vidéosurveillance
je ne sais pas je suis pas certain que
ça apportera vraiment des solutions de
sécurité mais de toutes les façons il me
semble me semble pas que ce soit à la
hauteur des ddd des problèmes de nos
concitoyens ont parlé tout à l'heure de
la souffrance des souffrances qu'il faut
en temps je voudrais quand même dire que
des gens qui souffrent et qui votent
front national dont +1 que cela aussi il
faut les entendre et je le crois pas que
ce soit d'investir ou de gaspiller
l'argent public dans des équipements de
sécurité qui en quoi que ce soit va
améliorer la situation de l'emploi parce
que là par contre on est vraiment sur le
sujet principal
un lancement qui nous préoccupe tous on
lisait il ya quelques instants on
parlait d'un g6 avec emilie la droite
qui avait déjà remporté les cinq
départements en mars dernier s'est
offert hier soir la grande région un
vote historique puisque le compte à
rebours est lancé dans 18 jours on fait
le décompte ça fait plus de 40 ans qu'on
en débat la normandie est divisée depuis
1956 et dans 18 jours il y aura plus
qu'une seule grande normandie
finie la haute et la basse normandie
enfin vous dites je sais pas si tout le
monde est d'accord autour de cette table
oui apparemment
régions et départements seront dirigées
par la droite vous propose d'écouter les
réactions de trois présidents de
départements c'était hier soir suivant
30 m la nouvelle grande normandie
elle se fera avec un alignement de
planètes inédit les cinq départements
gérés par la droite la plupart des
villes et des villages en normandie sont
gérées par la droite et le centre
et demain la grande normandie est géré
par ma famille politique donc par
définition c'est historique et je suis
très heureux il n'en demeure pas moins
que le pays va mal il n'en demeure pas
moins que beaucoup de colère est
exprimée à travers ce scrutin notamment
lors du premier tour il faut pas être
aveugle pour voir quand même qu'on va
pas pouvoir continuer comme avant et
qu'il faut être humble dans cette
affaire là l'état décidé et c'était son
choix respecté de faire de rouen la
capitale administrative et donc nous
nous pensons pour des raisons
d'équilibré pour des raisons d'ailleurs
de centralité géographique que la
capitale politique doit être
effectivement la ville de caen ce qui
répartit au combien équipe et ta ble
ment et qui permet naturellement de voir
tous les territoires je pense au havre
je pense à cherbourg je pense
naturellement à alençon le président du
conseil départemental de l'orne sera
très heureux dès demain matin d'ouvrir
le débat avec le nouveau président pour
voir pour la construction du programme
spécifique de l'orne qui est le
département qui doit être le plus aidé
puisque c'est le moins peuplé
voilà différentes réactions hier soir
sur notre antenne on entend des gens
léonce dupont le président du
département du calvados dire il faut que
qu'en soit la capitale politique de la
grande normandie
j'aime adressé à havrais en l'occurrence
hubert 9 genre de là bas qui vous êtes
juste milieu joli tout appel devait
alors président de la communauté
d'agglomération du conseil régional de
haute-normandie hébert de saint thomas
donc là on mettons la capitale politique
où doivent siéger
les élus régionaux à partir du mois de
janvier
bah écoutez je suis accessoirement
géographe et vous le savez les
géographes normand c'était pour me
pencher sur lui avait planché sur le
sujet par an et il est clair que en
termes d'aménagement du territoire il
fallait équilibrer les pouvoirs on fait
une réforme pour donner un vrai pouvoir
la région la moindre des choses c'était
de donner à cette région un équilibre et
une organisation des pouvoirs qui lui
permettent de rayonner sur tous les
territoires et donnant n'oublier aucun
puisqu'on sait que il ya la grande
crainte du déclassement des territoires
ruraux
alors notre réponse était bien
évidemment de mettre de l'état a placé
le chef lieu administratif de la région
à rouen nous décidons de mettre le chef
lieu à une politique à caen et bien
évidemment alors je coupe court à toutes
les supputations il n'y aura pas
d'itinérance du conseil régional ils
restent vacants non siègera à caen point
rouge et on va pas siéger dans un train
en heures creuses sur le fou quand
lorsqu'on annonce qu'on va faire une
très économe
sinon oui ou alors à un moment garde
yvetot pendant que ça nous arrive de
temps en temps alors soyez un petit peu
plus sérieux ça ne veut pas dire je suis
je le pense souvent une citadelle où et
quand
en ce qui concerne l'équipe du pouvoir
mais évidemment ça ne doit pas se
résumer aux deux villes nous avons parlé
aussi du triangle de du tri pôle
métropolitain rouen caen le havre bien
sûr et nous souhaitons qu'il y ait des
services déconcentrés qui souhaitent
situé dans toutes les autres grandes
villes et puis nous avons un très grand
arc périphérie de cherbourg en passant
par alençon jusqu'à dieppe bien
évidemment et c'est tout ça que nous
devons mettre en réseau et faire
fonctionner voilà alors on va revenir à
celui maintenant qui a
remporter cette élection hervé morin
c'est donc le premier président d'une
normandie réunifiée un symbole pour lui
pour lui qui défend la normandie
réunifiée depuis près de 20 pour
maintenant une victoire presque
inespérée on l'a vu hier au vu du
scénario qui s'est joué hier soir même
si le natif de leur était donné
vainqueur et ce dès les premiers
sondages franck on s'en souvient voyez
ce portrait signé catherine leconte
normaux pur jus et rémora aînés 1,61 à
pont-audemer au départ rien ne le
prédestinait à la politique mais ses
grands parents agriculteurs dans leurs
et son père directeur d'entreprise lui
donne vite le goût de l'effort et de
l'économie à la sauce normande
son credo quand il est en campagne faire
renaître l'identité normande pour faire
de la normandie une marque vous assure
que c'est pas une idée loufoque
après sciences po et une maîtrise de
droit il autres d'abord comme conseiller
à l'assemblée nationale avant d'y siéger
comme député de l'eure à partir de 1998
maire d'epaignes depuis 20 ans il
intègre la gare de rapprocher de france
au bo avant d'être élu au conseil
régional de haute normandie où il défend
déjà l'idée d'une réunification
pour nous c'est un enjeu d'avenir et
c'est notamment un enjeu en matière
économique et en matière de pour
dimensionner au mieux les intérêts des
normands dans un dans une bataille
européenne et mondiale
une région dont il démissionnera en 2007
à sa nomination comme ministre de la
défense de nicolas sarkozy pendant trois
ans il travaillera aux réductions
d'effectifs dans l'armée fondateur du
nouveau centre il s'installe en
parallèle dans le paysage politique
normand et obtient finalement la tête
d'une liste d'union de la droite et du
centre pour la bataille électorale de la
grande normandie dans laquelle cet
éleveur de pur sang fort de son
expérience se lancent à bride abattue
gens peuvent se dire mort arrive à
savoir faire avoir une expérience
ministérielle une expérience politique
ça peut servir dans des périodes
compliqué ça rassure ça peut être
rassurant ça peut être aussi un atout
important pour pouvoir discuter au
niveau national avec un executive
résultats à 54 ans ce père de quatre
enfants réalise enfin son rêve
il sera le premier président de la
grande normandie voilà philippe c'est un
peu la consécration pour hervé morin
clairement hier soir c'était ça un hervé
morin qui s'est dit en plateau avec nous
plutôt ouvert aux propositions de la
gauche il a raison de le dire parce
qu'il va avoir besoin de toutes les
forces qui composent y compris au sein
de l'opposition n'a cru comprendre qu'il
était prêt à jouer l'ouverture
alors on se souvient c'était sa
troisième chance en 2015 échec sanglant
avec monsieur ruffenach deux listes
différentes il avait disparu entre les
deux tours on s'en souvient en 2010 il
avait estimé que c'était trop dur pour
lui de siéger dans l'opposition là ça y
est il a sa chance c'est un de ceux qui
a produit depuis très longtemps la
réunification il a le pouvoir il ya une
majorité stable donc de ce point de vue
là ça devrait aller
un mot pour conclure du côté de la
gauche on a bien compris en écoutant
tout à l'heure monsieur jumelles que le
front gauche faisant tu es libéré de
tous au sein d'union de la gauche et on
peut supposer que ce qu'on entend sur le
plan national les divergences qui voit
le jour depuis déjà quelques temps
eh bien on va on risque de les retrouver
dans les exécutifs où la majorité est à
gauche ça n'est pas le cas de la
normandie bien évidemment et comme on
avait pu le voir lors du vote du budget
c'était l'an dernier au conseil
départemental de la seine maritime pour
la première fois le parti communiste
avait voté contre le budget de la seine
maritime on arrive parce qu'à la fin de
cette émission on découvre un dernier
dessin de chaunu libérer la normandie ne
sont pessimistes
oui bah oui parce que c'est quand même
l'image de hervé morin celle
débarquement et j'espère qu'ils nous
libérera de ce manque d'amour que nous
avons contrairement aux bretons qui sont
très fiers de leur territoire merci
merci à tous les cinq d'avoir par merci
à cette émission spéciale
après ce second tour des régionales et
après la victoire donc d'hervé morin qui
deviendra le 4 janvier prochain
réunion à rouen 1
premièrement régionales la première du
mois donc il deviendra le premier
président de la grande normandie merci
emilie j'étais ravie de présenter ces
élections avec vous demandez en quercy à
jean françois clerc à toutes ces équipes
qui réalisait cette émission et puis
rendez vous bien sûr dans le journal ce
soir
nous y reviendrons largement à ces
élections régionales merci à vous et
puis très bel après midi sur france 3
merci bonne journée